so it's great to see you here at
collector mania I've been having good
time today yeah it's been great I don't
do too many of these but every time I do
I have an amazing time and it's just
I've kind of still slightly amazed that
people want to meet me so that's always
nice and and it's great just sitting and
seeing everyone in in costume and the
effort people go to just the sheer scale
of the things just it snows obviously
you know that Joffrey is gonna meet his
maker as it were but what was your
reaction when you thought it happened on
screen pure elation no it was I think
for a lot of viewers it was probably
quite quite a mixed bag because I mean
everyone everyone loves to hate Joffrey
and the hang-ups testament to Jack
gleason's performance that people really
did despise the guy I mean everyone that
I know that likes the show in the run-up
to you know in the rent of the season
was saying I really hope that Joffrey
gets it this season and but that but
then but then when he finally does go
you you realize what a great character
was and what a joy it was to watch Jack
Gleeson perform every every week so see
ya a mixed bag mixed feelings I mean I
think Westeros will be a better place
but you know HBO will has definitely
lost their sort of
a great character you forget his
position you know you forget that he's
the king because he's insulted on a
number of occasions but that's sort of
that look in his eyes and that just the
way that he can the way that he quickly
reassert his position by being a
complete bastard I think this is
fantastic
Joffrey didn't have the qualities you
need to survive and go his parents'
because he's now dead what kind of
things do you think you need another
very rough world I think you just need
you need you need so much guile I think
in Game of Thrones we you know we've
we've seen on numerous occasions that
being virtuous doesn't quite cut it you
know being well-intentioned this is just
not good enough you you you you have to
you have to play the game and you have
to know how to play people are
forgetting to each other and to keep
yourself out of the fire and I think I
think that's the most important thing I
don't think physical prowess is even
necessarily at that that big an issue
you've just got to know how to handle
people more than anything and that's
what obviously Joffrey's terrible that
do you think kendrys got what it takes
yeah I think he does I think he's I
think about it he's you know not only is
he known easy to have that physical
strength there you know is actually it's
not required but I think is definitely a
bonus
I think he's because of the upbringing
he said because the childhood is a
because the hard knocks that he's had to
take at various points and someone that
knows what it's like to be at the very
bottom you know in the very bottom rung
of society
he's also someone that knows knows what
it's like to soar feel you know a little
bit a little bit cast adrift and a
little bit alone so I think I would like
to think as a result that he that he's
quite a maybe quite a compassionate
leader but then again you know I also
think that it would be pretty cool if
Genji came back and you know which may
be changed in a in a negative way kind
of the way that my years getting more
dark as the season goes yeah I think
there might be an extent to which you
can lose a bit of always think that
Kendra was being a realist still has
somewhere in there has faith in humanity
in human nature and I think he you know
he starts to believe that a bit when you
know when he starts to quit with the
Brotherhood he starts to feel like he
belongs and then they betray him in his
eyes and then all of a sudden Melisandre
is telling him all these things and he
starts to let himself believe that and I
think he's getting increasingly more
frustrated with the fact that he he
trusts people when they let him down and
and maybe the scope for like you know if
that one you know if that just happened
one too many times
yeah I think I could take against you
too quite an interesting place - how
likely are we to see you return to our
small screen with some time soon
I'm possibly say who knows how would you
like to come back in a blaze of glory
obviously I mean I think you know I
think part of the part of the idea
behind it
having Kendra's of drift off for a
little while is so that you know when
and if the return is is is made it it
makes it all the more impactful I think
you know he needs to have been given
time to to experience certain things and
turn to their for change in a
significant enough way so that went you
know when he returns it's it's of some
importance now opponent I'm George RR
Martin's say relatively recently that
there might be the possibility of a game
of Thrones movie what do you think about
that and what would you like to see in
in that big-screen spectacle yeah I
think um I think it's a great idea
and you know but not only for the
reasons that that Jorge said you know I
think a lot of what he was talking about
was budgetary and they're saying you
know that from where he wanted the story
to go you know the TV budgets not really
gonna cut it and then you've got it
you've got to do a story like that
justice I think and so the kind of
budget that a movie would allow in a
movie or three would be would be great
and I think I think more than that I
I think the making it an event you know
I mean I think I think
Game of Thrones has been great in
restoring event television a little bit
I think we sort of lost that with you
know Sky+ and people can kind of watch
things whenever they want and and a lot
of you know a lot of box sets people
kind of they're only aware of them after
a few seasons and then they kind of
they're catching up in people at various
points but I think with Game of Thrones
it's getting to the stage where most
people are up to date and most people
are waiting for Monday night waiting for
the you know the new episode and I think
I think that's that's really good and I
think a film that has that kind of
following taste at the next level it
actually like midnight screenings and
people dressing up and stuff and I just
think it would be I think it would be a
great way to round off
a pretty amazing story if you could see
any characters face off on the show kind
of do battle who would you like to see I
love watching the hound fight anybody
the hound and Daario naharis because I
the Haris that he's obviously if
Daenerys is watching and is trying hard
and that's a bit of spice and thing and
that the Hound bite could not care less
about that kind of things fighting
machine I think had been interesting
face up finally tell us some more about
your monsters dark continent I know that
we're all looking forward to coming out
in September the trailers just dropped
and I know that you're very excited to
see as well
yeah it's been a it's been a bit of a
year slow burner because we shut it a
year ago now so we've been we've all
been sort of quite anxious to see
whether whether the finished article is
you know meets our expectations because
I think sometimes you get a you get a
feeling when you're on certain jobs that
what you doing might might be something
a little bit different or a little bit
special then I think we had that a
little bit on monsters and you're still
when you're still very aware of the fact
that it's still a British film when
although there's a there is a kind of
there's a precedent there is a sort of a
fan base there it doesn't necessarily
mean that it's gonna it's gonna break
through but I really hope it does
because we know we all put a lot of a
lot of kind of poured a lot of ourselves
into it and
and yeah had a great a great crew
working on it and I've seen you know in
the trailer that the effects look great
and I think that's that's one of the
things that you're anxious about because
you can you can do as bit of work as you
like on on set but if you if it's a
genre piece like that you know the
production values have to be have to be
high and it looks amazing
what was your favorite moment about
making that movie going to Detroit was I
mean we shot in Jordan and Detroit and
they're both fascinating places but
Detroit for me was it was just even more
incredible because I mean I'm a city boy
I always lived in cities Detroit is a
kind of city on its knees essentially
financially it's completely bankrupt and
and I didn't know an awful lot about it
before I knew I was going there at which
point I did quite a bit of research it's
got an amazing history at the point of
its at now there's led it to this point
which is that it's just a ghost town
it's this thing that it looks like a
metropolis as it looks like this great
American city the skyscrapers and all
kinds of things but it's just empty
there's no one there and there's 90,000
abandoned buildings and but making
certain areas nature started reclaiming
some of them now it's like this
it's post-industrial wasteland really
and I mean great place to shoot because
it just looks it looks airy and weird
and there was a few other films there at
the same time as there Ryan Gosling's
movie was called how to catch him on to
there but I don't know what it's called
now I think it's changed and so yeah it
was great in the cast occur and Matt
Smith we're filming that in Detroit at
the same time as me but yeah that was
for me that that experience was amazing
and I'm sure I think Detroit is the
city's gonna rise like a you know
phoenix from the flames but I'm kind of
glad that I got to see it as it is a bit
of a cautionary tale Joe it's been
lovely to speak to you thanks so much
again as always and we're looking
forward to monsters of course and also
we hope that team Kendra is back in the
show very soon team bastard child
you